scp-163 is an extraterrestrial Sapient
organism housed within a specialized
enclosure by the SCP Foundation the
creature which is two meters tall
possesses a cylindrical body with a
circular mouth a head eight three
jointed legs and specialized limbs
including two for feeding and two sets
of arms it's single eye which extends
around its body allows for a 360 degree
field of vision but only an ultraviolet
light wavelengths scp-163's biology is
significantly different from terrestrial
life its endoskeleton resembles
cellulose its blood uses nickel instead
of iron or copper for oxygen transport
and it employs DNA but with different
coating for amino acids Personnel
interacting with scp-163 wear isolation
suits to prevent cross-contamination and
are required to follow protocols to
ensure the creature's well-being
scp-163's communication methods are not
well understood but it does produce a
sound wave and displays emotions through
skin distortions above its eye it has
shown gestures indicating affirmative
and negative responses